malgré la présence de l'armée des
milliers de colombiens ont manifesté ce
lundi pour le sixième jour consécutif
des manifestations en dépit de
l'interdiction de se rassembler à plus
de 50 personnes en raison de la
situation sanitaire et qui on donnait
lieu à des violences ces derniers jours
depuis le début de la protestation une
vingtaine de personnes ont trouvé la
mort dans ces rassemblements alors que
plus de 800 autres ont été blessés
l'opposition accuse l'armée de tirer à
balles réelles
pointé du doigt le gouvernement rejette
la faute sur des groupes dissidents des
farc sont les sauces banda los km imité
fans ce sont ces vandales qui se
camoufle et ont développé des actes
préméditées organisées et financées par
des coupes dissidents des farc et de le
nl qui cherchent à déstabiliser
certaines régions à des fins
particulières quand propose et aux
particules à cause de la protestation
un projet de réforme fiscale du
président yves indiqué il prévoyait
notamment d'imposer les personnes
gagnant l'équivalent de plus de 545
euros par mois dans un pays déjà
lourdement impacté par la pandémie de
coronavirus selon un rapport
la pauvreté touche 42 5% de la
population et le taux de chômage
dépassait des 18 % en février
conséquence le président colombien
annonce finalement le retrait du projet
dimanche les sollicitent aux halles
congrès à la république je demande au
parlement de la république de retirer le
projet déposé par le ministère des
finances c'est de traiter d'urgence un
nouveau projet de réforme fiscale
issu d'un consensus et d'éviter ainsi
l'incertitude financière est vitale
un certain nombre et financière face à
l'échec de la réforme le ministre des
finances a quant à lui démissionné ce
lundi
malgré l annonce du retrait le comité
national de grève a de nouveau appelé à
manifester massivement ce mercredi
arrivé au pouvoir en 2018
la popularité du président du hockey n'a
depuis cessé de baisser et s'établit à
33 % selon un dernier sondage
son mandat s'achève lui en ou 2022